vier seltsame gerüste thronen auf einem
einsamen berg in alaska
diese bauten wirken nicht gerade
fortschrittlich er wie riesige
werbetafeln aber zur zeit ihrer
entstehung war dass die allerneueste
technologie
eine kriegsruine verwittert nahe der
grenze zu nordkorea
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man dort
lebend wieder herauskam war sehr gering
und
wenn dann war man fürs leben gezeichnet
1 fabrik komplex in einem idyllischen
tal hat eine dunkle vergangenheit
auf den zweiten blick ist das gebäude
nicht so ein laden wie es zunächst
scheint eine schwere metalltür
eingelassenen eine dicke steinmauern wen
wollte man aus oder einsperren
und in einem mittelalterlichen schloss
passieren grausame morde
entweder hat die blutgräfin eiskalt
junge mädchen getötet
oder sie war eine mächtige aber
unschuldige frau die von skrupellosen
rivalen reingelegt wurde
[Musik]
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
die ländliche slowakei rund 90 kilometer
von der hauptstadt bratislava entfernt
im siebzehnten jahrhundert sollen sich
hier grauenvoller szenen abgespielt
haben
oben auf einem hügel steht ein bauwerk
das offensichtlich zur verteidigung
dienen sollte
es scheint zu klein für eine festung und
nicht druckvoll genug für einen palast
einer der beiden türme führt in eine
drei meter tiefe grube
ein loch im boden das aussieht wie ein
kerker
von einem anderen turm ist nur noch eine
ramponierte wand erhalten das ist mehr
als natürlicher verfallen da hat jemand
nachgeholfen
die schießscharten in den mauern zeugen
von einer zeit der angst und gewalt
es war der perfekte ort um ungebetene
gäste abzuwehren dort war man jederzeit
gefechts bereit
der legende nach soll sich ihr
furchtbares zugetragen haben sie
zeichnet ein düsteres aber auch ein
einseitiges bild
im jahr 1610 dringen mark erschüttern
die schreie aus dem burgkeller
junge frauen erleiden unaussprechliche
qualen
[Musik]
acht mädchen sind dort gefoltert worden
marcela bednar over ist mit den
furchterregenden geschichten
aufgewachsen
die mädchen wurden gedemütigt man hat
ihnen psychische und sexuelle gewalt
zugefügt
in ketten gelegt haben sie auf ihr
schicksal gewartet
sie mussten tage lang nackt im kalten
keller stehen
die geschichten klingen verstörend wir
wissen nicht was tatsächlich passiert
ist aber jeder der sich ein wenig mit
dem ort auskennt sagt das ist grässlich
gewesen sein muss
dieburg schacht tietze wird im 13
jahrhundert erbaut um die grenze des
ungarischen reichs zu sichern
rivalisierende adelsfamilien wechseln
sich als besitzer ab bis das anwesen
1604 in die hände der gräfin elisabeth
batterie feld sie soll die geschichte
der burg für immer verändern
[Musik]
bei ihrem einzug war bathory anfang 40
und frisch verwitwet auf die einfachen
dorfbewohner muss sie unglaublich
glamourös gewirkt haben man sagt ein
jugendlicher glanz habe sie umgeben
batterie r die burg von ihrem
verstorbenen ehemann einem mitglied der
einflussreichen norderstedt familie
sie erbte all seine besitztümer und
wurde zum oberhaupt eines wohlhabenden
adelshauses
damit war sie eine der mächtigsten
allein stehenden frauen ungarn in einer
zeit in der frauen meist als bürger
zweiter klasse galten
junge dienerinnen kümmern sich um ihren
haushalt und kochen für sie
das eine adlige in ihren 40ern junge
damen in hauswirtschaft unterweist war
damals nichts ungewöhnliches die mädchen
zogen eine zeit lang zu einer fremden
familie und bereiteten sich so auf die
ehe und ihr späteres leben vor
doch in diesem haus scheinen durch und
durch finstere mächte am werk zu sein
man erzählte sich dass viele mädchen die
in dieburg zogen nicht mehr zurückkehren
am 29 dezember 1610 stürmen soldaten die
burg und durchsuchen das gelände
bei ihrer suche fanden die soldaten ein
totes und zwei schwerverletzte mädchen
es hieß die beiden waren gerade noch so
am leben und grausam zugerichtet
[Musik]
soll bereits tot gewesen sein die
anderen beiden sollen mit letzter kraft
auf ihre peinigerin gezeigt haben
der gräfin eilt der ruf voraus
barbarische lehrmethoden anzuwenden
angeblich hat sie ihre schülerinnen für
jede kleinigkeit bestraft wenn sie
einlagen verkehrt gefaltet wasser
verschüttet oder sie auch nur falsch
angesehen haben
das heißt die strafen reichten von
ohrfeigen bis hin zu blutenden wunden
und mit der zeit wurde es immer
grauenvoller
[Musik]
soll sie mit nadeln gestochen haben sie
hat sie angeblich gebissen sie mit honig
geschmiert und den bienen und ameisen
vorgeworfen hatte im schnitt sie mit
scheren folterte sie mit heißen
metallstäben manche mädchen hat sie
angeblich draußen erfrieren lassen
eines der schlimmsten verbrechen soll
sich im kerker abgespielt haben
elisabeth bathory wollte das haupthaus
für sich haben weil ihre tochter anna zu
besuch kommen sollte
ihren dienerinnen gefallen sie so lange
in dieburg türme zu ziehen
die mädchen mussten tagelang stehen
manche konnten danach kaum noch laufen
und
wenig später waren sie tot
angeblich hat elisabeth bathory 600
mädchen ermordet das wäre weltrekord
die gerüchte stehen in enger verbindung
mit batterie es vergangenheit
ihre familie war berüchtigt für
alkoholexzesse
inzest und perverse sexualpraktiken
als bathory in ihrer jugend
migräneanfälle bekam meinten ihre
angehörigen sie sei von einem dämon
besessen
das heißt sie haben blut ihrer opfer
gebadet dass ihr jugendliches aussehen
erklärt hätte
die soldaten nehmen batterie fest sie
wird verurteilt und in den burgturm
verwandt die tyrannen herrschaft der
vermeintlichen blutgräfin hat ein ende
doch wie die meisten geschichten hat
auch diese zwei seiten
[Musik]
eine sache ergibt keinen sinn
elisabeth bathory soll 600 frauen
ermordet haben
aber wir haben nicht ein einziges grab
gefunden keine sterblichen überreste
nichts
der mann der bathory damals festgenommen
und die leichen gefunden hat war das
oberhaupt einer feindlichen adelsfamilie
aus der nachbarprovinz
ziemlich verdächtig
batterie war sehr gebildet sie
beherrschte vier sprachen und sie war
eine frau was sie zur zielscheibe machte
auch wenn die beweislage nicht eindeutig
ist mein gefühl sagt mir dass in der
burg etwas grässliches passiert ist
solche geschichten haben meistens einen
wahren kern
entweder war elisabeth bathory eine
eiskalte massen mörderin die reihenweise
junge mädchen umgebracht hat oder
sie war eine mächtige und unschuldige
frau die von skrupellosen rivalen aufs
kreuz gelegt worden
wahrscheinlich werden wir es nie
erfahren
[Musik]
ein jahrhundert später plündern rebellen
die burg
heute ist sie ein beliebtes ziel für
touristen die auf den spuren von
elisabeth bathory wandeln möchten
[Musik]
im kargen nordwesten alaskas ragen vier
sterne bauwerke empor
[Musik]
diese gekrümmten türme stehen etwa 250
kilometer von russland entfernt auf den
gipfel von mount
dort gibt es keine bäume und kaum
vegetation
einzig diese vier riesigen gerüsten die
aussehen wie werbetafeln aus einem
gemälde von
hätte man werke aus einem museum für
moderne kunst an stahlgerüste befestigt
einst hatten die seltsamen
konstruktionen eine wichtige funktion
dort war streng geheim er hatte die
höchste sicherheitsstufe denn das war
bahnbrechende technologie
bei näherem hinsehen wird klar dass es
kommunikationsgeräte sind vielleicht
radar oder mikrowellen technologie
schwer zu sagen
[Musik]
für richard berner will den ehemaligen
bürgermeister der nahegelegenen stadt
nun hat der ort eine besondere aura
manchmal fühle ich mich wie bei den
pyramiden
ich bin stolz darauf was menschen
erschaffen haben diese anlagert wirklich
funktioniert
ihr ursprung reicht zurück ins
neunzehnte jahrhundert
damals wurde alaska zum us territorium
nachdem es vorher lange zeit zu russland
gehört hatte die usa hatten den russen
alaska abgekauft es war ein gutes
geschäft niemand ahnte dass russland
einmal unser größter geopolitischer
gegenspieler werk wurde
1949 macht eine schreckensnachricht die
runde die sowjets haben in kasachstan
erstmalig eine atombombe gezündet ein
atomangriff auf die usa wird plötzlich
zu einer realen bedrohung
[Musik]
in den 50er jahren nimmt das nukleare
wettrüsten zwischen ost und west fahrt
auf
richard berner will erinnert sich
vor dem schlafengehen habe ich an die
bomber gedacht die da draußen rund um
die uhr auf ihren einsatz warteten
das war der kalte krieg für mich als 18
jährigen
doch wie soll alaska einen möglichen
angriff aus der benachbarten sowjetunion
rechtzeitig melden
wenn auf einmal sowjetische bombe auf
den radargeräten erschienen wären hätten
die verantwortlichen sofort eine warnung
absetzung
das problem war jedoch dass es in alaska
damals nur altmodische kupferdraht
technologie zur kommunikation gab
in alaska gab es früher kaum straßen
thiede grafen oder telefonleitungen von
gnome aus konnte man nur jeweils einen
anderen absetzen wegen der großen
entfernungen war die kommunikation sehr
schwierig dazu kamen noch störungen
durch die polarlichter
telekommunikation funktioniert zu der
zeit nur mit sichtverbindung eine
schnelle informationsübertragung über
große distanzen ist praktisch unmöglich
alaska braucht dringend eine neue
infrastruktur
doch welche technologie ist der
herausforderung gewachsen
alaska spielte eine interessante rolle
in der geschichte des kalten krieges
weil es so nah an russland und am
nordpol liegt
am ende des zweiten weltkrieges kämpfte
man gegen einen feind aus dem süden eine
bedrohung aus dem norden war neu
kein system kann effektiv vor
sowjetischen bomben flugzeugen warnen
erst diese funkstation bringt die wende
sie bindet alaska an das
telekommunikationsnetz der air force an
diese türme waren teile der distanz
early morning line das war ein radar
netz von der spitze schottland über den
nordatlantik island grönland und kanada
es hat den ganzen ort wohl abgedeckt
man nimmt an dass das weit im namen für
alaskas weiße schneelandschaft steht er
ließ gilt als akronym für alaska
integrated communications and
electronics
eine typische wireless anlage besteht
aus vier schlüsseln die sich paarweise
gegenüber stehen und über funksignale
mit anderen stationen kommunizieren
wegen der entfernung konnten sie das
funksignal nicht einfach in einer
geraden linie zum empfänger sind
also richteten sie es schräg nach oben
dort prallte es an der topos fairen
schicht ab und kam hunderte kilometer
entfernt wieder herunter
der name der technologie troposphäre
funk oder english shop skater
hat viele vorteile gegenüber anderen
technologien durch den umweg über die
troposphäre brauchen die sendeanlagen
keine sichtverbindung
das ist besonders in den bergen alaskas
nützlich
die wireless stationen konnten über
hunderte kilometer kommunizieren und
mehrere gespräche zeitgleich übertragen
und das wichtigste sie waren abhörsicher
die signale sind ausschließlich an den
ort gereist für den sie bestimmt waren
sie abzufangen war praktisch unmöglich
das system bietet einen wichtigen schutz
vor möglichen angriffen im kalten krieg
[Musik]
funkstationen überall in nordamerika
sollten vor feindlichen bomben
flugzeugen waren später als die
bedrohung durch langstreckenraketen
größer wurde kamen noch radarsysteme
hinzu sie konnten raketen auf dem weg
ins landesinnere der usa frühzeitig
registrieren
binnen drei jahren errichten die usa 31
weitere stationen die erste geht 1956 in
betrieb
doch der bau erweist sich als schwierig
der nächste highways 1100 kilometer
entfernt anchorage 1200 kilometer die
beringstraße und russland fliegen
praktisch nebenan
sie mussten die bauteile einfliegen oder
auf hundeschlitten harrer schafft
arbeit unter schwersten bedingungen
es war ein kampf gegen die zeit und
gegen das wetter
hunderte tonnen metall mussten
eingeflogen und schnellstmöglich
zusammengebaut werden
das ganze musste zudem stabil genug sein
um den harschen stürmen alaskas
standzuhalten
zu diesem zeitpunkt ist es die modernste
telekommunikationstechnologie der welt
[Applaus]
auch hawaii und die philippinen waren
über das tropisch götter system
verbunden aber in alaska war es am
effektivsten
keine andere technologie hätte die
region so wirksam vernetzen können
doch das kostet das system verschlingt
damals mehr als 300 millionen us dollar
ursprünglich ging man von sechs
mitarbeitern und 25 kilowatt leistung
pro anlage aus am ende brauchte es 20
personen und etwa 120 bis 180 kilowatt
noch bevor weit alles vollständig
fertiggestellt ist macht ihr eine neue
technologie den platz streitig
ironie des schicksals
ab 1958 vollständig in betrieb
da war mit sputnik bereits der erste
sowjetische satellit im all
die satellitenkommunikation war deutlich
verlässlicher und man musste keine
funkantennen der eisigen tundra
aufstellen wo sich das betriebspersonal
ja ein jahr aus dem internet vor
[Musik]
war es ein erfolg ich würde sagen ja es
hat uns geholfen dorthin zu gelangen wo
wir heute sind
ab 1970 ist weiter alles nur noch als
ziviles telefonnetz in gebrauch
die letzte funkstation geht schließlich
mitte der 80er jahre außer betrieb
[Musik]
an der grenze zwischen nord- und
südkorea finden sich spuren eines lange
währenden konflikts
[Musik]
die entmilitarisierte zone zwischen nord
und südkorea ist sehr gefährlich
wir reden hier nicht von einem relikt
der vergangenheit
dort herrscht bis heute ein
kriegsähnlicher zustand
vom gipfel eines hügels kann man nach
nordkorea hinüber sehen und dieser ort
liegt genau in seinem schatten
von dem bauwerk sind kaum mehr als die
außenwände übrig was ist dort passiert
das gebäude ist nicht nur herunter
gekommen sondern komplett verwüstet ohne
die stützpfosten würde es einstürzen
es ist keine natürliche verwitterung es
scheint als hätte es jemand absichtlich
zerstört
das rätselhafte bauwerk liegt südlich
der grenze zu nordkorea am rand der
demilitarisierten zone und es wirkt
vollkommen fehl am platz
jemand hat dem koreanischen grenzgebiet
ein gebäude nach sowjetischem vorbild
erachtet
an der art der architektur sehen wir
dass es aus dem kommunistischen
nordkorea statt
aber warum ist es komplett zerstört
und wieso steht es in südkorea
[Musik]
nach jahrzehnten unter japanischer
kolonialherrschaft wird die koreanische
halbinsel nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
aufgeteilt
die rote armee brachte die nordhälfte
unter ihre kontrolle
die amerikaner auf der anderen seite
besetzten riesig
sie haben das land entlang des 38
breitengrads gesplittet so ist eine
grobe nord süd grenze entstanden
[Musik]
das gebäude liegt im landkreis schere
war damals noch ein stück nördlich der
demarkationslinie
janko kim ist in der gegend aufgewachsen
seine familie hat die turbulente
geschichte des bauwerks miterlebt
das gebäude gehörte der nordkoreanischen
arbeiterpartei
genauer gesagt dem kreisverband von
czerwonn
als die kommunisten 1946 die gegend
einnahmen haben sie hier ihr örtliches
hauptquartier errichtet
zweifellos soll das imposante gebäude
autorität ausstrahlen
es ist das einzige mehrgeschossige
gebäude der gegend alle anderen sind
eingeschossig und aus holz
zusätzlich wurde es auf einer anhöhe
erbaut sie haben den ort absichtlich
gewählt um die bevölkerung
einzuschüchtern
dieses gebäude sollte die überlegenheit
des kommunismus verkörpern
und die pläne der kommunisten gehen noch
weit darüber hinaus
bonn war die größte stadt am 38
breitengrad darum haben sie hier diese
zentrale errichtet von hier aus haben
sie das umland regiert und ihren angriff
auf südkorea vorbereitet
[Musik]
langfristig wollen die nordkoreaner die
gesamte halbinsel erobern
[Musik]
in der grenzstadt share one herrschte
immer eine gewisse anspannung viele
nordkoreanische truppen bahn dort
stationiert ihre anwesenheit hat für
große unruhe gesorgt
1948 ruft spaniens statthalter kind
lösung die demokratische volksrepublik
korea aus
wollte nordkorea so beherrschen die
stalin die sowjetunion beherrschte
brutaler diktator der im interesse des
staates und der regierenden partei jede
form von individualität
unterdrückte
hatte zuvor für die rote armee gekämpft
mit ihm an der spitze nordkoreas
steuerte die halbinsel auf einen krieg
sucht
für die einwohner von sharon wirkt das
örtliche hauptquartier der kommunisten
wie ein bedrohlicher schatten
noch heute erzählt man sich von den
schrecklichen dingen die dort passiert
sein sollen
es war ein ort voller schreckliche
geheimnisse
angeblich wurden personen die sich dem
kommunismus oder den regeln widersetzt
hatten her geschleppt gefoltert und
getötet
das problem ist leider dass die menschen
die die verbrechen begangen haben
allesamt in den norden zurückgekehrt
sind
[Musik]
heute gibt es keine aufzeichnungen mehr
die die geschichten belegen
[Musik]
schon bald sieht kim il sung die chance
die gesamte koreanische halbinsel unter
seiner herrschaft zu bringen
im 19 25 juni 1950 überquerte die
nordkoreanische armee den 38 breitengrad
und
überrollte südkorea regelrecht
die nordkoreaner haben sich einen weg
über die halbinsel gebannt und die
gegnerischen streitkräfte in die enge
getrieben
die südkoreanische armee und die
amerikanischen besatzungstruppen wurden
bis zur stadt pusan im süden
zurückgedrängt
die sache schien erledigt
doch in letzter minute greifen weitere
us truppen unter dem kommando von
general macarthur ins kriegsgeschehen
ein mit einer invasion hinter
feindlichen linien
die usa haben den koreakrieg zur sache
der vereinten nationen gemacht sie haben
es geschafft die un auf ihre und
südkorea seite zu ziehen so konnten sie
die nordkoreanische in version gerade
noch rechtzeitig zurück bringen
die streitkräfte auf seiten der
südkoreaner gewinnen die kontrolle
zurück und kämpfen sich vor in richtung
norden
doch für viele kriegsgefangene ist es
bereits zu spät auf dem gelände dieser
ehemaligen
wasseraufbereitungsanlage nahe bonn
endet ihre tragische geschichte
nach dem krieg wurden hier unzählige
leichen geborgen kaum ein ort in der
gegend hat eine so dunkle vergangenheit
[Musik]
ihrem rückzug wollten die nordkoreaner
sichergehen dass keiner der
vermeintlichen volksfeinde überlebte
der krieg hat ein czerwonn viele narben
hinterlassen aber hier war es besonders
schlimm
bevor die kommunistische armee endlich
abzog hat sie unzählige gefangene
getötet darunter viele zivilisten
der gedanke daran bricht mir das herz
die menschen von sharon werden das nie
vergessen
die insassen aus der parteizentrale
würden dort hingebracht und hingerichtet
[Musik]
und 300 menschen bei diesem blutbad
umgekommen
die südlichen truppen dringen weiter
richtung norden vor schon bald werden
sie das zentrum von jerome erreichen
als die soldaten 1950 in die stadt
einfallen nehmen sie sofort das örtliche
hauptquartier der kommunisten ins visier
ihr angriff hinterlässt deutliche spuren
das sind die ketten abdrücke eines
us-amerikanischen panzers der das
gebäude zerstören sollte ich nehme an
damit wollten die streitkräfte stärke
demonstrieren
schließlich war es ein feindlicher
parteisitz und das örtliche
hauptquartier der nordkoreanischen armee
zwar übersteht das gebäude den angriff
doch sein ende ist bereits besiegelt
wenige monate nachdem die truppen auf
südkoreanischer seite das gebiet
eingenommen haben werden sie auch sharon
zurückgedrängt
die nordkoreaner wollten vermeiden dass
so ein wichtiges politisches symbol dem
feind in die hände fällt also haben sie
alles niedergebrannt und zerstört die
gesamte gemeinde bis auf 1 dieses
gebäude das hier noch heute seinen
schatten wirft
1953 unterschreiben bei der parteien
einen waffenstillstand eine neue grenze
entsteht nur wenige kilometer nördlich
des ehemaligen partei sitzes
[Musik]
seither ist das gebäude ein mahnmal aber
auch ein symbol der hoffnung
[Musik]
wir dürfen die vergangenheit nie
vergessen
sie erinnert uns an unsere wichtigste
aufgabe korea wieder zu vereinen und
gemeinsam in wohlstand zu leben
[Musik]
im norden tschechiens nur wenige
kilometer entfernt von der deutschen
grenze gibt eine ländliche szenerie
rätsel auf
er ist ein sehr schönes entlegenes tal
mit gepflegten wäldern sauberen bächen
und einem netten dörfchen hier und da
eine idyllische gegend
man würde vermuten dass die menschen
hier seit jahrzehnten glücklich
gesäumt von hohen bäumen steht ein
lehrer gebäudekomplex
träume die sich über ganze stockwerke
erstrecken mit halb pfeiler stützen die
decken ab sie muss etwas sehr schweres
gestanden haben
dies waren einmal große fabrik doch nun
sind sie verlassen und überwachung warum
sollte jemand diese teuren anlagen
erbauen nur um sie anschließend
aufzugeben
erste hinweise finden sich auf der
rückseite der gebäude
man sieht die überreste eines lagers und
daneben einen großen schornstein nie ein
gutes zeichen
dieses eisen tor hütet ein dunkles
geheimnis
man steht vor einer steinwand mit einer
riesigen metallteile und fragt sich was
war dahinter
warum all diese sicherheitsvorkehrungen
ein blick auf die anfänge des
fabrikgeländes luft das geheimnis zu
lüften
[Musik]
im neunzehnten jahrhundert soll hier ein
neues wunder material hergestellt werden
bittere jossa kennt die geschichte genau
wir sind hier in einer halle der
ehemaligen textilfabrik von franz reindl
sie wurde 1867 als eine von dreien im
rat steinatal erbaut
[Musik]
in diesem gebäude gab es 16.000 spindeln
die spinnmaschinen standen zwischen
diesen säulen es war eine der größten
fabriken der gegend
die fabrik rabstein jahns gar produziert
baumwolle im großen stil
für die örtliche bevölkerung ist sie ein
finanzieller segen
diese fabriken haben arbeitsplätze für
mehrere generationen geschaffen sie
haben die örtliche wirtschaft beflügelt
mit dem erwirtschafteten geld konnte man
zum beispiel schulen bauen und eine
kapelle restaurieren
der gewinn aus den fabriken hat also
viel gutes bewirkt
die gebäude wirken auf den ersten blick
harmlos wäre da nicht dieses ominöse tor
man sieht dieses schwere eisentor und
fragt sich was verbirgt sich dahinter
wen wollte man ihr einsparen oder fahren
halten
[Musik]
und beim näheren hinsehen wird schnell
klar dass nicht alles so idyllisch war
wie es scheint
das textilgeschäft floriert bis der
markt 1929 zusammenbricht
ende der 1920 er jahre begann die
weltwirtschaftskrise mit katastrophalen
auswirkungen für die industrie in mittel
und osteuropa
hunderte arbeiter hier in der gegend
haben ihre jobs verloren jobs die sie
brauchten um ihren lebensunterhalt zu
bestreiten
die fabrik muss ihre tore schließen und
liegt mehr als zehn jahre lang brach
bis die nazis das gelände 1942 in ihre
gewalt bringen
die deutschen hatten schon lange ein
auge auf böhmen geworfen erst haben sie
1938 das sudetenland besetzt und dann 39
den westen der tschechoslowakei und
sie haben bereits einen plan für die
fabrikgebäude
[Musik]
mit baumwolle konnte die wehrmacht wenig
anfangen wenn sie 1 brauchte dann
flugzeuge
nur wenige hundert meter entfernt werden
die arbeiter einquartiert die diese
flugzeuge bauen sollen
die deutsche wirtschaft und die deutsche
kriegsmaschinerie mussten am laufen
gehalten werden
dafür haben die nazis unter anderem
zwangsarbeiter eingesetzt
das kz-außenlager rabstein entsteht
[Applaus]
wir sind hier im außenlager rabstein das
1944 für knapp 700 insassen errichtet
wurde
da die deutschen nicht genug arbeiter
finden konnten haben sie gefangene
hergebracht und einen elektrozaun und
die berater gespannt
die deutschen haben ihre arbeit von
zwangsarbeitern verrichten lassen sie
haben sich praktisch sklaven gehalten
[Musik]
das naziregime basierte nicht nur auf
militärischer stärke und einer verqueren
rassenideologie es basierte auch auf
sklavenarbeit
dabei behandeln sie nicht alle
gefangenen gleich
ein erlass von reichsführer ss heinrich
himmler gab vor wie menschen aus
verschiedenen nationen behandelt werden
sollten
die niederländer galten als aria und im
weitesten sinne als deutsche und wurden
darum nicht bewacht sie durften halbwegs
normal leben und in privatunterkünften
wohnen
die franzosen gelten auch als arisch
ihnen ging es ebenfalls noch
einigermaßen gut
die menschen aus osteuropa hingegen die
polen und russen wurden in lagern mit
stacheldrahtzäunen eingepfercht und
durften nur essen was sie dort bekam
wenn sie irgendwo am straßenrand einen
apfel gepflückt haben erwartete sie eine
harte strafe
das ziel der nazis war alle menschen die
sie als minderwertig betrachtet zu
versklaven und sie in den tod zu treiben
die bedingungen in den lagern waren
darauf ausgelegt alles aus den arbeitern
herauszuholen bis sie schließlich tot
umfielen
[Musik]
die zwangsarbeiter fristen ein
qualvolles dasein zwischen fabrik und
konzentrationslager und schon bald
sollen die bedingungen noch härter
werden
zwischen dem 20 und 25 februar 1944
haben die alliierten gezielt die
flugzeugwerke der luftwaffe bombardiert
das war ein harter schlag für die nazis
also haben sie eine task force auf die
beine gestellt und entschieden die
produktion zu dezentralisieren und in
den untergrund zu verlegen
sie brauchten unendlich viele arbeiter
die tunnel zu graben war eine
heidenarbeit vor allem da sie mit
dynamit und spitzhacken hatten
die gefangenen sollen vier tunnel in das
gestein treiben
die nazis sind so versessen darauf mit
der produktion zu beginnen
dass sie die maschinen her bringen bevor
die tunnel fertig sind
der lärm die dämpfe der mangel an
tageslicht es war die hölle
[Musik]
an dieser stelle ist während der
tunnelarbeiten ein teil der decke
eingestürzt
320 arbeiter aus dem konzentrationslager
sind dabei erschlagen worden
sie haben sich im wahrsten sinne des
wortes zu tode geschuftet
anfang 1945 steht das ende des krieges
kurz bevor doch die zwangsarbeiter unter
tage armen davon nichts sie schufteten
litten starben nicht nur für eine
grausame sondern auch für eine
aussichtslose sache
dann keine zwei monate bevor die
wehrmacht kapitulieren soll ein erster
funken hoffnung
im märz 1945 wurde den gefangenen klar
dass das ende des krieges bevorstand und
sie eine chance hatten leben da
rauszukommen damals landeten fünf
sowjetische fallschirmjäger auf dem
gelände ohne dass die deutschen sie
daran gehindert haben am 8 mai 1945
erscheinen die deutschen wachen nicht
auf ihren posten als
die wachmänner nicht mehr zur arbeit
kamen dämmerte den gefangenen dass die
deutschen den krieg verloren hatten
die alliierten waren bereits auf dem weg
um die gefangenen zu befreien und die
nazis hatten die flucht ergreift
am ende dieses schacht sehen wir löcher
für dina mit stangen die
sprengkörper wurden hineingesteckt und
gezündet aber in diesem fall kam es
nicht mehr dazu weil der krieg vorbei
war
mit der ankunft der polnischen armee
endete die arbeit an der unterirdischen
fabrik
die zwangsarbeiter in rebstein konnten
ihre spitzhacken niederlegen und sich
überlegen wie sie nach hause kommen
würden
[Musik]
mittlerweile verwaltet die gemeinde das
gelände
die überreste des lagers und der tunnel
erinnern an das leid das menschen hier
ertragen mussten
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen
manche ruinen erinnern an dunkle zeiten
andere waren einst leuchtende beispiele
für technologischen fortschritt und
hoffnung stille zeugen vom
erfindungsreichtum
unternehmergeist und tatendrang